[Music]
damn my last words I would be thinking
about it too hard and I would probably
just die before I got a chance to say
anything all right I'd want to be able
to give advice to someone so live each
day and don't get too wrapped up in
what's going to happen worried about
what is happening to my mother I love
you for everything you've done and I'm
sorry for any pain I've ever caused if I
could choose my last words I'd probably
say
I'm sorry for not doing all the things
that I wanted to do with everybody
that's probably what I'd say I'm going
home
live and let live it was a fun ride
abide see you send me the love of God
for God be kind for everybody is
fighting a hard battle that is a deep
question if I could choose my last words
they would be music
music I'll leave that person with a
with a question of what about music as I
pass away
[Music]
I would say phallus interesting I don't
know actually maybe like I'm hungry I'd
probably say something like I thought I
wouldn't even know that I said it you
know what I mean
that's it I just feel like [ __ ] it's
like the perfect way to end a life
hold my beer I should have packed the
parachute myself
[ __ ] you all of you [ __ ] all of you I
don't know I don't know if I'm gonna
have last words you know I mean I
shouldn't delete in that at least I'm
free I love you and I love myself I hope
everyone takes a piece of me with them
to live through
I love you B toward all my family and my
friends I love you and take care of
everybody you love and that would be
towards my family and friends I had a
good life
I saw everything it's kind of
interesting is when you're doing a to
store and you're planning like a funeral
like you have to sum up what someone
else very close to you last words would
be inhale they'll be memorable memorize
you know memorialize death and I'm like
sitting here thinking well I didn't
really get to say this about myself or
will it be other people in how they saw
me like with my mom she was really into
William Shakespeare and writing so it's
really easy like her famous quote was
always be thine own self be true so
that's what we put on her tombstone it
was pretty easy but I think about it do
I have like the quote well what will
people really say about me you know well
I get to say it or well family members
and friends really be saying it
like what is more important if it you
know good sometimes I think deaths and
funerals are really for the surviving
people not really for you so maybe it
helps them go on I don't know I guess it
just depends on your prophecy
tell the others that I love
I'll always be with I remember
even if it will be hard it will affect
on the thing that we should all move on
it's part of life
and I hope I would feel I will I hope
that by the time I go I wouldn't feel
you know bad about my life
something it would be I love you
it would be don't be sad because I'm
gone
I'm always here
and it's gonna be okay it's gonna hurt
for a really long time but I've always
part of you because my brother passed
away and that's what I would want to
hurt him who said he loved me I know
it's gonna be okay
that I was gonna miss him for a really
long time but then he's always a part of
me and will always be a part of me and I
wish I could have heard I love you
rosebud
he's I mean it's Orson wills Welles film
Citizen Kane and in it his one true love
and his life was a sled it was a mystery
people tried to figure out was it a
person was a place and I've already
worked out a code with my family that
should I be dying that word will
encapsulate I love and miss you all that
was easy
I already worked it out
[Music]
[Music]
you